y por qué
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
sabe usted qué significa este gesto y
para qué sirve aunque ya se había hecho
viral en 2020 ahora vuelve a cobrar
relevancia al haber sido utilizado por
una menor en eeuu para denunciar que
estaba en peligro la llamada señal de
socorro nació en canadá pero ahora ha
llegado a una gran parte del mundo
gracias a internet como estas son varias
las campañas que se mueven en línea con
las que se busca concientizar sobre el
maltrato y el acoso empezamos
la noticia sobre una menor que fue
rescatada en eeuu tras pedir ayuda a
través de un gesto que se cree aprendió
en la red social tick tock se ha hecho
viral en redes sociales y ha ocupado
titulares internacionales de acuerdo con
las autoridades días después de que la
joven de 16 años había sido reportada
como desaparecida fue vista en el
asiento del copiloto de un auto que
viajaba por el estado de kentucky según
el reporte oficial
un conductor la vio haciendo un gesto
con la mano y pudo reconocer que se
trataba de un pedido de ayuda por lo que
contactó al servicio de emergencias 911
esto permitió la detención del sujeto de
61 años que transportaba a la joven y
que ahora enfrenta cargos de secuestro
con esa obligación en tick tock ese
gesto de la mano lo fue todo tan bien
diane ladd y de no haber sido
transmitido por la señorita y si no
hubiera habido alguien por ahí que
supiera interpretar lo que estaba
haciendo entonces quién sabe quizás esto
no habría resultado bien solucionado
cndh es el caso de esta joven vuelve a
darle popularidad a este gesto que
consiste en llevar la palma de la mano
hacia el frente
el pulgar hacia adentro y luego
envolverlo con los dedos restantes se le
llama signal for how o en español señal
de socorro y funciona como una especie
de código secreto para que una persona
solicite apoyo de manera discreta sin
tener que llamar la atención fue creada
en 2020 por la fundación de mujeres
canadienses ante los casos de violencia
machista que aumentaron durante la
pandemia cuando las mujeres quedaron
encerradas con sus agresores a raíz de
las medidas de confinamiento y sin poder
reportar abiertamente su situación así
lo dijo a france 24 susan duncan
vicepresidenta de filantropía de esta
fundación
eso incluye violencia de tu compañero
íntimo abusos sexuales abuso emocional y
sabíamos en abril al principio de
nuestro confinamiento que necesitábamos
encontrar algo que realmente abordará
esto
muchos abusadores monitorean el uso del
celular del computador así que queríamos
encontrar algo que no dejara un rastro
digital
entonces fue allí donde salió la idea
del gesto de la señal del socorro
queríamos tener un gesto simple con la
mano que alguien pudiera hacer para
dejarle saber a los demás que necesitaba
ayuda
desde que la señal de socorro salió a la
luz múltiples influencers y creadores de
contenido han replicado el mensaje sus
vídeos en los que explican cómo funciona
sean viralizado especialmente aquellos
en los que recrean situaciones donde el
gesto ha servido para salvar la vida de
mujeres y niños michelle los por ejemplo
fue una de las primeras en divulgar la
campaña a través de sus redes sociales
esta canadiense es una ex oficial de
policía y parte de su fama en tyc tots
se debe a los vídeos en los que brinda
consejos de seguridad y defensa personal
por ejemplo cómo librarse de situaciones
peligrosas michelle habló con france24
sobre la necesidad de seguir publicando
este tipo de contenidos
y creo que las redes sociales han
cambiado y continuarán cambiando
especialmente cuando en cuán impactantes
son realmente estas cosas
frears y continuamos teniendo creadores
de contenido en tick tock influencers
que publican cosas positivas y comparten
conocimiento de información que puede
salvar vidas va a sentar todo un nuevo
presidente en términos de lo que la
gente pública
y hacer siempre habrá otros contenidos
que la gente creará pero creo que vamos
a ver más cosas positivas
y el hecho de que esta señal goce de tal
popularidad también ha traído una serie
de cuestionamientos según la fundación
de mujeres canadienses la señal de
socorro ha sido adoptada por más de 200
organizaciones en 40 países y se ha
compartido en redes sociales millones de
veces esto ha llevado a que los
internautas se pregunten qué tan
efectiva será si un abusador también
aprende a reconocer la transmitimos
estas dudas así sean de un can quien
reconoció que esta es tan sólo una de
las muchas herramientas que se pueden
utilizar para solicitar ayuda y resaltó
otros efectos positivos que ha tenido
esta campaña
lo que es importante es que esta
historia está haciendo leer a la gente
sobre la cultura del estigma la cultura
del silencio y de vergüenza que rodea la
violencia de género muchas personas
tienen miedo de contarle a amigos y
familiares sobre lo que están
atravesando porque temen ser juzgados no
ser apoyados
como estas son varias las campañas que
han inundado internet desde hace años
para ayudar a denunciar la violencia de
género y el acoso de una forma discreta
en 2016 por ejemplo se lanzó en reino
unido a la campaña us foreign yo la que
al día de hoy sigue vigente y se ha
extendido a varias partes del mundo fue
creada para ayudar a cualquier mujer que
cree a sentirse en una situación de
riesgo en un bar ella podrá preguntarle
al personal del establecimiento por un
personaje ficticio llamado angela y
ellos sabrán qué hacer otra famosa
campaña es la llamada pizza a 911
usuarias en tick tock personifican a una
mujer que simula estar ordenando una
pizza en un restaurante cuando en
realidad se está comunicando con el
servicio de emergencias para denunciar
una agresión
el operador capta el mensaje y envía a
la policía el vídeo busca inspirar a
otras mujeres a denunciar
hasta aquí en revista digital recuerde
que si quiere repetir esta u otra
emisión de nuestro programa lo puede
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
punto frente 4 punto com
[Música]